short-term government bonds are paying
the highest rates in more than 15 years
I think right now we are actually
getting to the point where you shouldn't
be selling your bond now treasuries
don't have the cool factor of crypto or
meme stocks but when it comes to
risk-adjusted returns they're pretty
hard to beat right now we've seen a
notable pickup in individual purchases
recently but retail investors still
don't seem excited about treasury bonds
the government is going to need lots of
people to buy bonds this year so I made
a commercial to help boost their
popularity check it out
yo it's me your Uncle Sam and I want you
to get this money Uncle Sam that's right
players and playets if you trying to get
that paper paper the word is bonds
treasury bonds right now your man Uncle
Sam is hooking you up with mad cash
wow Uncle Sam's got the fat stacks
that's right get these bonds and help me
pay for roads schools hospitals and more
all the proceeds from your purchase of
U.S treasuries go right to the US
government okay maybe a commercial is
not such a great idea but treasuries
really are paying some of the best rates
this Millennium that's largely because
inflation is holding your 40-year highs
and the Federal Reserve is expected to
keep raising interest rates and thanks
to expectations for a U.S recession that
have inverted the yield curve investors
are getting paid a lot more to hold
bonds that mature in six months a year
or two years then to hold bonds that
mature in 10 years 20 years or 30 years
six month treasury bills is the most
recent auction paid an interest rate of
3.85 percent the highest since 2007 and
the yield on one-year treasuries just
Rose above four percent the highest rate
since 2001. that rate is nearly two full
percentage points more than you can earn
on many high-yield savings accounts and
it's more than 30 times the average
savings account rate in the U.S to be
sure treasury prices have fallen a lot
in 2022 but the great thing about bonds
is that if you hold them until they
mature you get back 100 of what you
invested plus the interest as long as
the issuer doesn't default plus as bond
prices fall yields rise meaning new
investors get to start off earning
higher interest rates investing in a
one-year U.S treasury bill is like
putting your money in a government
account and getting it back a year later
with four percent interest for your
trouble yeah a four percent return may
not match up to the potential gains on
Dogecoin but a one-year t-bill isn't
going to lose 75 of its value the way
Dogecoin has over the past year lots of
Wall Street investors have been putting
their money in government assets like I
bonds and treasuries so far this year
it'll be interesting to see if these new
higher yields and my super cool
commercial attract more retail investors
as well my name is Uncle Sam from the
USA I like to rap in an old school way
two three four percent Beyond and you
got to get you some of these treasury
bonds